- Une 19e visite du prince
Charles au Canada,
un voyage annonciateur
d'une nouvelle ère.
Le futur roi doit démontrer
qu'il est de son temps
et que la monarchie
t t t toujours pertinente.
PRINCE CHARLES, Son Altesse
Royale le prince de Galles
- Aujourd'hui plus que jamais,
nous avons besoin de l'esprit
d'initiative, de la compassion
et de l'humanité des Canadiens.
(coups de r)r)r)r)
- Le thème de la réconciliation
avec les Autochtones s'est
imposé. L'un des premiers
tstststs : le Jardin du coeur,
consacré à la mémoire des
victimes des pensionnats
autochtones.
(en anglais)
Avant l'arrivée, du prince
et de la duchesse, des leadersaé
des excuses ou des compensations
de la part de la famille royale.
Au minimum, la tournée
a e e e e e de braquer
les projecteurs sur
les enjeux autochtones,
croit ce représentant inuk.
À ses yeux, beaucoup
de mal a été fait au nomdededed,
il espère beaucoup de bien.
Pas d'excuses du prince
Charles, mais une courte
déclaration...
(en anglais)
"La réconciliation est
un engagement à long terme vers
la guérison", a-t-il plaidé.
♪ ♪ ♪
S'il doit composer avec
le passé, le prince Charles
tente aussi de démontrer
qu'il regarde vers l'avenir.
La cause des changements
climatiques, qui lui est chère,
sera au coeur de sa visite. M Me
cartes postales, sa mission
en est aussi une de relations
publiques, dans une monarchie
en pleine transition.
KARIM AL-DAHDAH, porte-parole,
Ligue monarchiste du Canada, Qc
- Il est aussi au Canada en
fonction de futur roi du Canada.
Donc, c'est très important
pour lui d'être vu au Canada
par les Canadiens.
- Une grande séduction à coups
de mises en scène gourmandes
allant de la crème glacée
locale...
(rires)
... àdededededede bière.
Une opération où tout
semble calculé pour tenter
de rapprocher la monarchie
des gens ordinaire